il a préféré s'éviter l'humiliation
ultime richard nixon démissionne à l'été
1974 après deux ans du scandale du
watergate
lorsqu'il sentait que la destitution
était inévitable en fait c'est la seule
fois de l'histoire américaine que l'on
sait autant approché d'une destitution
parce que la procédure est complexe
d'abord la mise en accusation qui doit
être voté par la chambre des
représentants à la majorité 50 % +13
motifs peuvent conduire à cette mise en
accusation la trahison la corruption ou
un crime ou délit jugés suffisamment
graves à des menottes
r chaque son nez dans le cas de bill
clinton
on est allé jusqu'au vote par la chambre
sur deux accusations parjure pour la
fait à monica lewinsky et obstruction à
la justice
mais ensuite c'est la deuxième étape la
procédure continue au sénat qui doit
voter aux deux tiers c'est-à-dire 67
voix clinton sera acquittée sur les deux
chefs d'accusation
l'autre cas c'est celui d'andrew johnson
mais ça remonte à 1868 lui aussi avait
été acquittée
quant à nixon ce qui a précipité sa
chute
c'est l'enregistrement d'une
conversation téléphonique il demandait
de faire pression pour que le fbi en
terre l'enquète du watergate mais un
excellent le mois à 20 qui a démissionné
il y avait les puits essentiellement
pour gagner un procès devant le congrès
quant à transcription est sorti d'un
échange qui avec son principal
collaborateur les allées des mots-clés
républicains l'ont abandonné
dévoilé la transcription de sa
conversation avec le président ukrainien
c'est ce que va faire donald kohn qu'il
veut jouer cartes sur table face aux
démocrates
ici mathieu poste radio canada montréal